لايك يانوفو كمان
[تصفيق]
رئاسه مجلس النواب الامريكي معركه طاحنه
داخل البيت الجمهوري امتدت فصولها لمده
اربعه ايام وعلى مدى 15 جوله تصويت وفي
لحظه من اللحظات توقف مستقبل مكارثي على
عضو جمهوري واحد وكاد المشهد ان يتحول من
الفوز الى مشاجره داخل احد اهم مفاصل
الحكم في الولايات المتحده
من اقصى يمين حزبه ابرز هاتنازل قد يضعف
منصب رئيس المجلس كالسماح لمشرع واحد
بالتقدم الثقه عنه تنازلات اخرى طارات
الانفاق الحكوميه ورفع سقف الدين وقد تنظر
بمواجهه مستقبليه
تهدد باغلاق حكومي ويوهوز سوالب كهرباء
سنراقب عمل الحكومه بدا من الانسحاب من
افغانستان مرورا بنشاه فايروس كورونا الى
استخدام الاف بي اي سلاحا سياسيا سنستخدم
موقعنا في اصدار الاستدعاءات والرقبه على
الانفاق علينا تامين حدودنا واعاده امريكا
الى الطريق الصحيح
واداراته من صداع فقد ابدى استعداده
للتعاون مع هذه القياده الجديده مثله مثل
زعيم الاقليات الديمقراطيه حكيم جافريز
لكن جافريز ذكر ايضا بان حزبه لنهادنا على
مبادئه
الديمقراطيون في مجلس النواب سيضعون دائما
القيامه الامريكيه قبل حكم الفرد المطلق
والخير قبل التعصب الاعمى والدستور قبل
الطائفيه والديمقراطيه قبل الغوغاء والفرص
الاقتصاديه قبل
التطرفين من اهميه ما حدث يبرز التساؤل
عما اذا كان شلل الايام الماضيه هو من
تجليات الديمقراطيه الامريكيه ام انه
اختلال في عملها
الان هو اننا نمضي قدما كبلد لكن منقسمين
لان لدينا كونجرسون قسم واغلبيه ضيقه في
مجلس النواب وهذا لا يصب في مصلحتهم في
ممارسه سلطتهم في الحكم الجمهوريون مثل
يقولون انهم يفضلون فتحه تحقيقات قبل اي
شيء اخر وظيفه اولئك الاشخاص هي سن
التشريعات وهذا تخلل عن مهامهم وليس جيدا
لمستقبل الحزن
ستدخل الايام الماضيه سجل تاريخ الامريكي
دون شك لكن قد يكون المشهد الذي لن ينسى
هو توقف عمليه التصويت على صوت مشرع واحد
مشهد ينذر بان طريق المصاعب لم ينتهي بل
بدا للتوب بسناب كويك الجزيره واشنطن